reaction videos
that's what it's all about isn't that
right ken that's right i have oh i am so
happy you've introduced me to reaction
videos saved my life playing games for
living
[Laughter]
[Music]
i thought we're gonna learn from the
best today ken
i see
we're gonna react to reaction videos
that's right
oh yeah and we're doing it purely so
we're gonna rate every single reaction
channel as well do you remember like two
days ago when i was like he's like i
reacted mr beast and i was like i gotta
react to reacting to mr beast oh now
we're reacting to reactions
it all comes full-time i didn't have a
similar idea okay
okay like like it was original anyway
come on
sometimes i'm real desperate for years i
go to other reaction channels to see
what they're reacting to
okay and then i was like you know i
wanted to react to the reaction videos
maybe we'll learn something i don't know
i haven't actually watched sniper wolves
in a in a while so let's check it out
it's me today we're checking out some
cool things you've probably never seen
before why i look naked i'm not there
are straps it is a halter this is the
okay
she does someone say that she's not
naked
yes she i noticed that they don't think
she said it to be fair yeah i'm thankful
she's got captions on there i couldn't
understand what she was saying so that's
good
uh what's your editor's name again scott
scott you better start adding subtitles
simon says
do you remember back in the day we would
edit like we would do our montage videos
i would do that i would spend days doing
that i was oh it takes so long geez if
you can see the the timeline of like
edits it was nuts it must be easier to
do now you think so no but i like this
thing so poor poor person who had to add
subtitles on sniper deepest swimming
pool in the world okay it doesn't look
that big right and then wait till you go
inside what there's the whole entire
atlantis in there
i've seen this actually come on and she
clearly has as well
well just wait until you see what's
inside what what's inside what
see
this is something i can take away from
this already is because when i react to
anything i never watch it before i do
and sometimes it's a mixed bag you know
sometimes i regret watching it
amazing yeah yeah totally kind of like
the video we do sometimes and we just
end up talking about anything but the
video
yes yeah so like there's nothing
actually here so let's just how how was
your weekend
all right more stuff that we haven't
seen an abandoned school i really went
down an abandoned school what kind of
school did you go to snap
and you see that hole at the bottom it
goes down even further
and
what do i do if i want to go exploring
if i do if i drown the lifeguards in
there then go get me out on time they
make you sign a waiver before you go
swimming it's very fast i feel like
videos have gone so fast lately like all
the best performing ones we are clearly
way too slow we're boomers who's just
like behind we are
we're boomers and so you gotta
you gotta slap it full of edits to keep
your attention and you gotta make sure
there's no down time if you see any dip
you know you gotta you gotta change what
you're doing go back and look at your
watch time
no time to reflect why whatsoever just
like boom boom boom hit him hit him with
her okay should we try to do the same
type style of commentary no we should we
should do it together we should just
yeah yeah at the same time yeah all
right so we're reacting to the deepest
swimming pool in the world here we go
all right wow that must be something
oh my god dude look how deep it goes
it looks like it's breaking school
like uh it's all just fun but uh yeah
it's intentional right there's a reason
that you do right yeah she's doing
really well for a reason time yeah
from my experience you receive the most
growth when you target the younger
audience right and so to make things
quick and snappy and add some spur
squirrely effects and all this other
stuff it catches their attention and
gets them you know glued to it for a
little bit instead of like us boomers
talking you know they've already clicked
off and went watch somebody else and
came back see if we're still talking and
we are we also got we forgot to take our
shirts off ken so it looks like we're
naked
my buttons stuck luckily stop again stop
it
what's wrong with this fan why is it
built like that it's not a fan it's a
hat wow all right that's actually pretty
neat though i thought they just like
they only did the subtitles in the
beginning there's hope side
i wonder why the subtitles are only in
the beginning maybe because we don't
have their volume or something so you
can read it you know what i think i know
where it is it's kind of obvious when
you think about it you know how you
hover over a video and it starts like
playing it's you know yeah it's to get
that those people in
is it this always starts it's me yeah do
you shoot oh i guess it does now doesn't
it yeah i thought it used to like start
just like randomly yeah somewhere yeah i
don't do anything actually i learned
something from sniper there you go um
i'm not gonna do it though but
don't worry inside i won't make it okay
sniper wolf i think beats a tier the a
tier yeah i think best here s tier i
mean everyone everyone just basically
rips her off these days so that makes
sense
yeah yeah even the thumbnails
yeah you're right that's another aspect
of sniper wolf is everyone's doing her
thumbnail you have like eight different
faces you put on a red background and
stick it beside whatever
your video is about
she's done the red background thing with
the reaction face and then everyone
started copying it yeah what about the
red that's so popular no one knows all
right moving on to the next reaction
channel oh speaking of squeezing down
videos to just over eight minutes long
so you can get those mid-rolls in there
here we are mr beast's reacts how about
that okay all right
well so much sense actually i love
oneness at least yeah it's so weird how
youtube changes in ways that we don't
even like acknowledge like i used to
make five minutes videos all the time
and then youtube changed it to okay well
now if you want to make any money off
your video you have to make it at least
10 minutes all of a sudden all videos
are 10 minutes and then youtube is like
no no really you need like a lot of
watch time and all of a sudden videos
are like 20 30 40 minutes an hour and
then we're still stuck in that you know
what yeah yeah exactly now they're like
you know what [ __ ] you you're just
making them short now and it's like god
damn it
make up your [ __ ] mind what are you
oh my
god not tick-tock
goddammit
youtube's gotta compete with literally
all of it you remember we had to make
google plus accounts just to log into
our youtube stuff
picture what a joke that was
i think you still actually have to use
it don't you they merged it with some
other stuff but yeah yeah they did the
same story over and over again is like
oh this thing is popular let's copy it
and make like the crap version of it and
then
in four years maybe it'll be decent when
nobody cares anymore that's basically
what happened to youtube gaming is that
you know there's a flop and now
after they've paid for people to stream
then it's starting to have some success
yeah who would take that all right so
when we're watching hydraulic press
how can they they have the same font
can they not change the font
maybe they have the same editor maybe
well i don't know i doubt it call that
mr
oh my [ __ ] god it's the exact same
well who did it first who's got who lays
claim to the fun i don't exactly i bet
neither one of them paid for the
oh my god that's insane
why
is that secret youtube hack it's not
just the fun it's also like the black
stroke on it too like oh yeah yeah even
the yeah that's true i'll see he doesn't
do it in all these hydraulic presses
which is why it was done by
professionals safety first up we got the
big behemoth versus a bunch of paper
does it just like cut a hole in the
middle this is what we need to do when
we start a video we introduce anything
like what we're doing what's going on
yeah it's
six seconds in and we're on to like the
clip this whole the six seconds of intro
has more like
effects than i have in my entire video
this is pretty much acting reacting to
like the new generation basically
why is it so fast i don't even know
what's going on who is this guy
is this the guy that used to donate to
ninja
[Laughter]
we got the big behemoth versus a bunch
of paper does it just like cut a hole in
the middle of it nope how long do you
think they record to get like these
eight super condensed eight minutes
depends on that it's making 12 minutes
[Laughter]
but it's so cut down how do they make it
so tight they have to record a long time
though i don't know
jeez
because i get bored of anything after 20
minutes i can't do it anymore
what if it just comes out and it's got
words all over what's the object like if
i'm watching hydraulic presses for more
than 30 minutes i got nothing else to
say at that point right that's true it
went squishy and got it like i'll look
at some clips that be great to react to
but then i go that's only like three
minutes how am i gonna get like a 30
minute video out of that you know but
impossible
they're seeing what it takes to cut it
in half and now they're trying this
pointy thing okay which i feel like this
is gonna work yeah
that exploded that did explode he got
halfway through though it's better than
anything else so for a ball two balls it
must be a male
you're busting my balls man all right it
doesn't look like the balls are busted
you know i don't know what's happening
nice is that what we gotta do
fast we gotta go fast all right let's
try it we also have to watch the clip
first and then pretend we haven't
watched it but we just did so it's
perfect okay cool cool yeah
because they're not
they're editing it to be like that
you're not yeah
right
that's a good point right right i was
thinking that's the part where we would
segue into a story about like strongmen
how they like take like phone books and
rip them in half and how that was cool
when i was a kid
i never did that but that just sounds
cool
ripping a phone book remember those
phone books whoa
put the boomer alert on it boomer alert
oh you just wanted us to look old again
i get it
stop stop with the anecdotes okay
clearly no one gives a [ __ ]
it's all about reaction and videos you
got six seconds talking about uh
telephone books go
okay
they like people's names
all right
all right that's it i'm not really too
sure we just watched on that you're
going to you got to
get a heart attack sniper war
yeah
no it's just making the science right
okay
let's see i mean
watching that video sad face sad face
for me sad face uh
i'm i was thinking happy face no yeah
well so maybe come on maybe in between
then
come on come on you can do it you can do
it you can go against the army of mr
beast i know it's i know
it's here obviously obviously this is
just the other side of like you got the
high energies fast stuff and then you
got like the opposite which is which is
charlie and he's just he's chilling i
don't know that is your air conditioner
on what is that noise that's my computer
gee is this thing's about to take off
man
around the room
they can't hear it because i have like
the software uh changing the audio but
for you yeah it's awful i'll turn around
one second so they know what ken is
going through there you go
enjoy everyone
oh this one's just the classic we've all
seen that
i think that guy's a completely slang
stud
i'm still asleep
sleep is so good sleep people
i remember when my girls did this on
twitch where they would keep the
gameplay for some reason like in the
corner that's the real way to do react
jesus i was just thinking the the video
that he was reacting to at the beginning
is a beer that i did like a month ago
any video i ever react to charlie's done
like four years ago yes yeah i didn't
realize he's seen it all man he's seen
all the good
is she advertising real world trading
right now i could so tell
like this hotel that you're sleeping
um
i must be speaking to an automated
recorder oh this is a guy today alicia
right um it's kind of hard to follow to
be honest i think she doesn't know
what's going on i think he should be uh
speaking constantly and adding some
panels this is not doing it for me i'm
sorry charlie that's a garbage
all right so we're rating charlie now
what would you rate charlie is penguin
zero if you're trying to find his stuff
penguins with the z and zero
okay
huh
what were you right charlie
[Laughter]
i think i think uh he didn't apparently
sad face because like what the [ __ ] was
he doing i didn't understand anything
i'm a huge charlie simp what are you
talking about oh wait sorry this is
wrong charlie
there we go
i thought he was joking do you think
that was him for a second
i'm so confused that's garbage oh
no how could you how dare you why where
you put him charlie is my favorite
person to have come on my channel and
make me feel like you put him down here
and then
what
come on i'm your favorite person
yeah of course you are you're my
favorite all right
there you go all right let's go watch
some real reaction videos ken this has
all been garbage so far
here we go here we go all right i need
to remind your dad
you see you're only here
at the beginning come on man
we're watching this video 52 million in
a day oh you you did it proud of you you
did the pretend that you didn't know
what you're doing thing at the beginning
heck yeah what did i do what do you mean
we're like you were scrolling you're
like oh my god how many views that have
we're doing this one you know you
already knew yeah of course what do you
think i just like hit record and i have
no idea what i'm going to record well i
know but that's the way you present in
the video right is that it i don't know
it makes it better for some reason i
don't know what it is
talking smack about the greatest channel
reaction channel i haven't actually
watched it it's not even number one in
trending what does it take to get them
trending then if you don't pick these
kimberly on the other day that's not
good enough see i'm adding some
interesting commentary
before the video has even begun okay
we're out of touch man
you haven't told me to look at your
graph yet oh you're right this is
painful i didn't realize how painful
this would be just sell your souls to
the devil kind of views mr peace what
what did you do pretending like i
wouldn't do that come
with
on
grand here i'll just show you the only
funny bit chris is on you hey victory
if you're wondering where she just fell
don't worry there's a giant foam pit
down there she's fine damn it
[Music]
you would
[Laughter]
it's one of the things that make people
laugh is that you do the opposite of
what others like the scary game where
everybody comes and gives the guy a high
five and you go there like smacking my
balls oh yeah yeah that's what it's all
about like
a girl falls through and you're like
everybody's like oh oh no but it said
you're like dang it
he's not dead i like this one shows up
like me looking completely beaten down
no where's my favorite one at where's my
favorite picture no this is that that's
too old i can't be bothered you know the
one this is this is good too it looks
like i'm like completely soulless i i
appreciate that i thank you the verge
yeah it looks like that that thumbnail
that you you've made for forever yeah
yeah
probably would like seats here you think
your c tier yeah c2 you're like that
you're like the youtube godfather man
whatever you do everyone else starts
ripping off so you know what no they do
that on sniper wolf now it's not true
anymore let's get real beat here at best
be here
yeah at least right okay i'll put eight
here
[Music]
no
[Laughter]
listen i don't watch my videos
let's see how long it takes for you to
get into the actual video it's going to
take a minute 30 seconds okay
maybe the cringiest
the cringiest person on night if you
guys hey right now who is oh it doesn't
say yeah this time it said you last
night
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know
it was just a preset thing you forgot to
do it
[Laughter]
it wasn't me and be funny yeah i can't
believe colleen is still doing she told
me i reacted to him like years ago
her smash life her
i was talking about debbie and how she
sleeps everyone
i'm going back and going back over the
previous video ken what are you doing
this is 20 seconds in and you're just
[Music]
the best graph on youtube right there
a minute and 20 seconds unacceptable i
don't know i mean look look my audience
is
just older all right there's more
refined than your entire layers hey you
got you got a analytics to back that up
bro i bet you my audience is older than
yours and smarter
do you think yours is older than mine
yeah i think it's so big
look look at what we're like yeah mine's
older than yours
oh my god what is mine the reaction
videos have conspired against this they
were supposed to bring this
i hate reality tv so much and i think
that's that's funny that i react to it
because i just can't stand it really
i hate it so much yeah i would like to
leave the room when mary would like be
watching
stuff like that back in the day yeah
so
very opinionated about trash tv which i
always find funny because it's like no
but like you watch it and you know it's
trash like
i put on my page where it's like other
channels that watch your videos
pewdiepie's number one and then
jacksepticeye oh
oh there's the pewdiepie highlights
channel well let's go
watch that okay so now we're going to
raid cinnamon touch game oh
like all the pictures of me are like
four years old at least
hey yeah hey yeah well
excuse me no no no no no
what is this b tier
b tier the greatest reaction channel of
all time
all right sorry
thank you thank you that's that's more
like it now put me down there with
charlie i'll i'll sit down there with
him
all right we're raining all day
right
yep all the reaction channels that
matter rated we did it we learned a
couple things here today but it's pretty
interesting thank you for uh joining me
we got six seconds to sign up
guys check out ken if you want to
subscribe to the video and make sure to
like subscribe in all the videos and i
see you tomorrow bye
you get two seconds come on there's your
birthday birthday